foreign
Mason is in Idaho hi Mason welcome to
the Ramsay show
how's it going better than I deserve
what's up
good so I'm 16 years old and me and my
brother do landscaping he's owner then
I'm his lawn care manager I'm going to
bring in probably about 45 000 this year
and closer to a hundred next year wow
good my Lord put that money as I'm still
living at home and don't have a ton of
expenses
pay off your parents house oh my gosh
wow what are you doing again
uh we we do lawn care and Landscaping we
do a lot of work we have a really fancy
golf course and we do a lot of property
down there so wow and you said your
brother's your boss and you're the lawn
care manager how old's your brother
he's 19. 19.
man yep I don't want to hear anybody
gripe about young people I mean I don't
want to hear anybody you can't find
something to do to work out there oh my
gosh he's projecting 100 Grand next year
why not why not that's a good story way
to go young man Mason now you're amazing
congratulations so your question is what
to do with the money
yeah I just was like investment what I
mean I'm definitely we're definitely
gonna move out at some point so save for
a house and all that but you're going to
you plan to go to college
no sir yeah I had a boy
what's wrong with college nothing days
not bad it's not bad but he's been smart
people smarter if they take the right
stuff if they need it he doesn't what
are you gonna do with your life Mason
uh definitely do this for the next
couple years become keep the manager
going definitely get up there we'll see
where this business goes it's definitely
growing we have four trucks and we're
having to buy a truck about every other
month it seems like but
um and then I don't know I'm kind of
thinking about maybe going into crane
work uh we have some cool classes over
here for that so
okay so the reason I'm asking all that
is not to be facetious it's to say
um the first and best investment someone
in your age group can make 16 to 26 is
in uh knowledge
that may or may not be a four-year
degree that may or may not be a a formal
series of classes but knowledge and the
thing you do need to do is be a
continual learner the rest of your life
so you're always going to conferences
reading books taking the occasional
class or whatever and uh and or in your
case maybe you are pursuing a certain
certification in crane operation or
whatever that is but I that's the best
use of this money because it's going to
give you the best rate of return
knowledge has the best rate of return of
any possible investment knowledge that
actually has utilitarian use in the
marketplace okay
that makes sense so yeah getting to
getting tooled up
you're getting your brain to in your
hands tooled up
to go do the next thing is always the
best Money Maker so that's where I want
you to do with money first
secondly yeah you can begin investing
and if you're if you don't need to set
us out a bunch of money for a four year
because you're not going that route then
um then you can start to think about
Roth IRAs file a tax return do a Roth
IRA get with a smart investor Pro
they'll help you do that and you can get
a real head start on that uh but if you
told me you were going to four year and
you needed this money for that I'd be
okay with you just setting it aside for
that either any of those are fine any of
those directions wow yeah really
impressive and see this is this is this
is going to be an entrepreneur
whether he takes the crane classes or
not I'm telling you this young man is
going to be creating jobs from a company
that he has started and this is the
entrepreneurial path and and I just
couldn't be any more excited to hear a
story like this and this is and I want
to be very clear and Dave's having fun
with me but I'm not anti-college I'm
anti-assuming that you have to go to
college to be successful and spend four
years time and money on a degree that
you don't even want and may not even be
able to use that's my position this
young man is an exhibit a of he doesn't
need the four-year degree what he does
need is as Dave pointed out beautifully
continuing knowledge continue to grow
and education is not exclusive to a
diploma at a fancy University education
is like Dave said reading books
listening to podcasts going to
conferences sitting with successful
business women and businessmen who are
winning in the field you want to be in
it so uh what a great story 19 and 16
year old brothers Dave yeah crushing it
had the exact same situation just the
other day I got some work being done on
one of our properties and two of these
big trackhoes come up major major cranes
right grabbing rocks grabbing stuff
right talking to the guy running it and
um he's like 30 years old and he owns
the thing he goes I started listening to
you no he's 40 years old I'm sorry he
said I started listening to you when uh
20 years ago wow I'm talk radio and he
goes I was I was running a I was cutting
grass I was running a lawn care and I
expanded into irrigation and we expanded
into tree removal and I bought a couple
pieces of heavy equipment and he said
now I own two million dollars worth of
heavy equipment I run a heavy equipment
operation wow 100 debt free the entire
time absolutely and uh high school
graduate yeah and he just kept working
did good work opportunities presented
himself he learned it acquired it did it
expanded it and I wonder how many people
he employs ah Bunch you see I mean you
got several million dollars worth of
equipment it doesn't sit idle that's
correct you know so he's creating jobs
yeah yeah this is how this is how
America Works boys and girls just a
little lesson for your economics class
that's true Karl Marx was not there this
is the Ramsay show open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
our friend micro would be real proud I
was just getting that kind of thing uh
we were talking about this in the uh
America's labor crisis event we did a
few weeks ago that you were a part of
and we were talking Mike and I were
talking about it on stage that the he's
not he's about as hardcore Pro Tradesman
as anybody you'll ever meet and almost
anti-college but not completely in
college but you know what we all agree
on regardless of how we're on that
Spectrum you land is uh a a useless
college degree is useless and two too
expensive that's right and so getting a
degree in German polka history you're
going to end up being a barista okay
this is just dumb all right and you're
gonna pay 250 000 for the opportunity to
draw somebody else's coffee and so um
nothing wrong with being a barista but
if that wasn't your goal and that's
where you end up by default that's what
I'm making fun of so don't you Barista
that don't let the Barista Union start
sending me hate mail okay but the uh but
he he our point was that the currency
all along has been knowledge yes and
somewhere the switch got flipped and it
the currency became a college degree yes
and it's not a college degree the
currency that moves you into the next
thing the thing you spend to go into the
next section of your life is knowledge a
college degree can represent that but it
is not the currency that's right